let's jump to this next story with a
hard Segway axios reports Elon Musk
threatens to sue the ADL after blaming
it for X ad sales slump
the long story short is that he said
that uh ad revenue is still down by 60
primarily due to pressure on advertisers
by the Anti-Defamation League that's
what advertisers tell us so now he's
talking about potentially suing the ADL
and this is big part of this Elon Musk
has said there will be a data dump on
all Communications between the ADL and
Twitter before he took over
holy crap if there are people who ran
businesses on Twitter
who use Twitter for a marketing tool or
for awareness building whatever that's
real monetary value and if the ADL
contacted Twitter to have them banned
I'd argue there's a very strong tortious
interference claim and if Elon Musk
releases all the communications the ADL
had with Twitter
the ADL thought it was safe we talked to
Twitter we tell them hey this person
should be banned Twitter says okay they
get banned ADL is not scared that
Twitter whatever leak those
Communications Elon Musk buys Twitter
and now he can open the floodgates if he
releases these communications the ADL
could be sued into Oblivion by every
account by your username could have been
Maga Trump for Life 773 whatever with
underscore seven and you have like a
your avatar was just a cartoon of trump
they go to Twitter and say ban this
person and you can argue they're
interviewing in interfering they're
defaming me and they're interfering in
my agreement that I have with Twitter
that I'm using for my business or
whatever it may be now that may be a bit
of a stretch but there are a lot of
accounts that had a hundred thousand
followers that made money on the
platform either it's just uh selling
T-shirts or doing streams or collecting
donations and their business was
destroyed by the ADL interfering in the
existing agreement they had with Twitter
in fact if you look at Alex Berenson
this one's really interesting not that
the Ada comes in to play a role here
this is the government but this is a guy
who has uh I don't know if at the time
he had a sub stack but you you
presumably you're selling subscriptions
on substack the government comes in and
says ban this guy even though he didn't
break any rules
so what happens he files a lawsuit he
wins the account gets reinstated imagine
all of the accounts targeted by the ADL
who did not break the rules but got
taken down because the ADL threatened to
lie about Twitter and claim they were
sowing hate or whatever
Elon Musk about to flow open the
floodgates again this could be really
really big I hope he does Sue I think
that's one of the best things that could
happen I I think one of the uh
one of the kryptonites of the American
social media General culture is that
there are people who can say this person
is bad and you should never speak to
them you should never have them on your
platform and that can have a Rippling
effect I mean maybe it's an honest count
but maybe it's just someone who posts
under their real name the ADL which has
its own political bias doesn't like them
well if you're banned from Twitter what
stops you from being banned from PayPal
PayPal from MailChimp from all of these
other organizations that say well we
heard that you were bad we heard that
you're not we're not allowed to support
you I mean there is a really serious
ripple effect that damages free speech
in this culture and the ADL has been at
the center of it for a long time
I love the idea that the ADL
Anti-Defamation League could get sued
for defamation yeah so people are
calling them the defamation leave yep
but they've been sued I guess for
defamation before 20 some odd years ago
they had to pay a fine I don't know
exactly what happened with that but this
is a key component to the narrative
manipulation in this country
organizations like the ad on the splc
lie lie lie lie lie lie all the time and
um that's a fact Southern Property law
centers had to apologize the ADL is also
to apologize uh for for putting out
false information
but this is what they do uh the example
I gave earlier is that there's this
group called the election Integrity
partnership that accused me of being a
super spreader of fake news and this is
why I use newsguard because now my
response to them is just oh I don't know
take a look at newsguard who certified
everything you said was fake news and
then ask them why they claimed it was
legitimate news don't look at me all I
can do is use newsguard but the game
they play is
they never exactly said what fake news
it was I was spreading the ADL will
accuse you behind the scenes you won't
even know about it and then the news
reports come out saying you did thing or
were accused of it they'll come out and
say
after being uh so-and-so got banned for
hate speech and then just like what did
you actually say doesn't matter then the
media can report it then regular people
hear it and then they start making
assumptions about you
for a lot of people like uh for instance
we had Steve Bannon on the show the
first time he was on this show I got a
message I got tons of messages from
people saying they never they thought it
was crazy they never actually heard him
speak
there was a meme that they had on Reddit
circulating and it was a picture of
Bannon that said this man thinks his
race is superior to yours and it's like
Stephen is not a white supremacist he
doesn't think that they make this stuff
up they hire people to spread
disinformation then they attack social
media organizations to get you banned so
you can't defend yourself
and and it's able to happen because it's
government utilizing private companies
to attack you know what would otherwise
be definitely Free Speech uh I got the
Ukrainian government put me on a kill
list and then I got banned from yeah
PayPal venmo twitch I got banned from
all these things after that so I don't
know maybe we could talk but I think the
I think the most interesting answer to
this and obviously any pro any solutions
can have problems but if you fully
nationalize big Tech and take it away
from these private corporations wouldn't
Free Speech have to be at least in maybe
a better way than it is today protected
on these platforms I don't really want
Biden Administration administering uh
Free Speech they have their own own
position on who gets to speak freely and
who doesn't but and they don't take like
Medicare away from people in the United
States because at least yeah because you
have different political views maybe in
Canada they do that but they do they do
Target your taxes based on your
political views they do do that right
not a perfect solution but you you I
don't know it's worth thinking about I
don't think I think it would create
another Monopoly controlled by the
government but the idea of forcing these
private companies to free their software
code to the people as like a government
action could could work because once you
have access to the devices or the
material software code you can make your
own version of the site and it can't ban
you I was going to say if the government
owned social media platforms it's too
much like Ministry of Truth for me I I'd
rather have someone private
neither are ideal but government's like
the worst option yeah it's just not gone
so well in China you know no I I I don't
necessarily agree if uh there was a
social media that was run like a public
utility that was maintained by by
government workers
it's it's very difficult for them to
come and shut off your water or
something like that the idea would be
only under strict specific regulations
could they take your your account down
like with a warrant right no don't get
me wrong sorry just there will be
corruption search warrants are required
to break into your house or for the cops
to come in and they might be able to get
a bunk warrant signed by a bad judge but
if your account is up and you incite or
commit a crime through you know saying
hey everyone go do this at this time
they go to a judge get a warrant the
judge says take it down they take it
down then you go and they can arrest you
or whatever but it could theoretically
work it I think it could and it's the
problems you guys brought up it's the
same exact problems we have today like
when I got banned from twitch one of my
viewers did a foil request found out the
the organization that wrote the whole
article to get me banned from twitch was
in Communications with the Department of
Homeland Security they're going back and
forth and suggesting names to get taken
down from these platforms over Russian
disinformation so you still you have
those problems today and I think you
would have those problems if you
nationalize Twitter or Facebook or
whatever but I think they would be far
less and if they did happen you could
always do a four-year request kind of
like kind of like with Healthcare like a
public private thing where you still
have Private health care insurance you
still have private social media but then
you could have a public social media
software X but yeah you'd have some sort
of Regulation but you don't actually
need government to run it you could
simply have regulation that states
accounts cannot be taken down without
a warrant signed by a judge so then for
someone let's so we have these we've
talked about that quite a bit actually
uh in New York for instance Occupy Wall
Street took place on what's called a
pops a publicly owned private space
so the land is owned by an organization
an entity but you can use it because of
an agreement they have with the city
which grants them certain liability
protections but also grants you free
speech rights even though it's owned by
somebody so Elon Musk can monetize can
put ads up he's the owner but he can't
remove people because he's made an
agreement on liability that's the way it
should be when Occupy Wall Street
happened they said we want our movies
people and they're like there's a
lawsuit and they're like you can't it's
a public space so free speech is allowed
you can't just claim private property
after the fact the same thing should be
true for Twitter once you're signed up
and on you have free speech they can't
remove you unless you commit a crime and
they get a warrant yep I was gonna say
though it seems like social media your
rights the rights of free speech aren't
being extended online fully as you know
like you can go outside of a Starbucks
CNN and you could say whatever you want
can't say whatever you want uh you know
on Twitter so I think if we fully
extended those rights we wouldn't need
to even have you know the government
take but you don't even you don't even
need government maintaining it like
these people these these private loan
public spaces are maintained by the
organization that own them and there's
some benefit usually could tax they get
a tax write-off or something they don't
got to pay taxes on it because it's open
to the public but then they pay to
maintain it in the instance of of
Twitter they get the lawsuit protections
you're not responsible for what anybody
says you can sell the ads but you also
can't remove people unless they're
breaking the law there are challenges
with that but I think the issue then
gets to what we've talked about before
if you go in public and you have a big
poster with porn on it you're going to
get arrested on obscenity charges or
something they're going to take it
they're going to rip to pull the sign
down they're gonna say you can't do that
Twitter should be the same thing I don't
understand how we got to the point where
reason Society still recognize you can't
go out in public and show loot images in
the and wave them right in the air but
on Twitter you can
on any social media platform
why is that you got to pay you show an
ID to get into a bar you got to show
id'd again to a casino you can't even
walk through a casino unless you're 21.
you can't even bring your kids to the
restaurant so a lot of casinos will do
this thing where the where the
restaurant is actually just on the other
side of security line so families can
actually bring their kids yet when it
comes to looking at adult graphic
content on the internet there's no
requirements yeah that's nonsense yeah
oh it's crazy and it
you know other countries aren't like
that in Asia China you don't have you
don't have that sort of stuff Russia is
doing away with that stuff and I think I
think at its core this the question of
this uh issue of
um hashtag ban theadl it's like all of
these issues of foreign or domestic
interference in private companies is
completely legal there's no first
amendment protection but Tim like you
said if you have some sort of a some
sort of a structure in place there that
guarantees free speech it would do away
anytime you have someone getting banned
or taken off for something other than
explicit content or illegal activity
criminal activity you know that's
immediately a free speech issue thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time